CHARLES VEST: OpenCourseWare
is a web-based program
that will provide free access to
primary materials for virtually
every course at MIT.
KRISHNA RAJAGOPAL:
The founders of OCW
had a transformative vision 20
years ago of offering access
to materials from the MIT
classroom openly, freely.
CURT NEWTON: They can learn from
them straight off the website.
They can download them
and carry them around.
They can remix them with
other kinds of materials,
mash them up in new ways.
They can share them
with their networks.
KRISHNA RAJAGOPAL: We're
getting about 22 million visits
per year.
We have more than 3
million subscribers
to the OCW YouTube channel.
It makes it the biggest .edu
YouTube channel in the world.
CURT NEWTON: It has captured
curious learners of all stripes
from around the world.
KRISHNA RAJAGOPAL: Several
thousand MIT faculty
have shared materials from
more than 2,500 courses.
CURT NEWTON: We're sharing
materials, not just
from the science, technology,
engineering, and math courses
and the management courses
that MIT is most famous, for
but also from the incredible
richness of our humanities
and social sciences.
KRISHNA RAJAGOPAL:
The impact of OCW
in opening learning for
millions around the world
is multiplied by the role
of educators elsewhere.
When they take
materials from OCW
and repurpose them and
use them and make them
part of their own teaching,
for each one educator that
does that, there's
dozens or hundreds
more people for whom the
opportunities to learn
are opened up.
CURT NEWTON: It
takes resources to do
what we do at OpenCourseWare.
It takes a lot of people and
time and energy and money
to cover the full
curriculum at MIT.
KRISHNA RAJAGOPAL: We
are right in the middle
of building the next-generation
platform for OCW.
We expect to roll it
out within a few months.
It will be mobile-friendly.
It will have much
better search tools.
What we teach it at
MIT changes with time.
How we teach changes with time.
We need a new platform
that will allow
us to keep the content at
OCW current and vibrant.
CURT NEWTON: Knowledge should
be free, and especially
knowledge that comes from
leading institutions,
institutions with the most
privilege behind them.
To give that back to
the world has never
been more important
than it is today.
So many of the challenges
that the world is facing
require the development, the
application, the testing,
the refinement of new
forms of knowledge.
KRISHNA RAJAGOPAL:
We firmly believe
that a world in which the
educational attainment
of millions of people
has been elevated
will be a better world.
This is making a difference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]